[Music]
today's question
comes from tree in kentucky he visits
daveramsey.com to ask
how do you fight fair as a couple when
you disagree
oh that is awesome what a question it's
a wonderful question this is a dave
question
not a bunch of lines not a bunch of
dehlonisms like talking about when he
was sad he was a kid no
how do you fight fair as a couple when
you disagree simple question
so here's my answer today my questions
are simple questions i'm just saying
i think you just said that on the radio
you're direct
i tend to run my mouth so here's what i
would say number one
i would always ask why are we fighting
for what
what's this disagreement about right the
second thing i would always ask is
what's the
what's the outcome going to be am i am i
digging my heels in on something am i
having a disagreement because i think
i'm right
am i just wanting to fight there's those
moments we just want to engage
and then the other thing is um the
number three is can i be heard
um am i speaking just to have said
something
or am i talking in a way that the other
person is going to hear me and sometimes
that means i got to be quiet in a moment
when i'm heated i got to get off-site
i've got to say things that i know
aren't going to push my wife's buttons
but it always goes back to the central
why are we even having this discussion
why are we fighting are we fighting for
10 things that have happened over the
last three weeks are we
are we having a disagreement right now
over one thing
right um that's really good what about
the fair part
um you know like i i know one of the
things i have learned
it's it's actually helped my marriage to
learn how to do conflict here at the
office
and so here at the office we fight i
mean we do conflict here
we eat it for breakfast uh but it's not
for the purpose of conflict or the
purpose of damaging the soul of the
individual
it's we're fighting for excellence and
so iron sharpener
i can argue with you and you and i can
have a heated exchange
and um but we have a level of trust that
it's not about
uh you not liking me me not liking you
it's about this thing
and we're just arguing about how to do
the thing better right
or whether to do the thing right or what
excellence looks like in the thing
but when you cross the line and you make
it personal
and i go yeah well i mean you're just
that guy
right then it turns to contempt versus
working on the problem
is that the part of the fair it's
knowing the boundaries
i know your boundaries i know my wife's
boundaries and when i intentionally
choose to cross them i'm not being fair
when i am because because she trusts me
i have permission to hurt my wife and
she's
got permission to speak into my world
and so when i wheeled that
unethically when i wheeled that sword to
hurt
right so that's me saying i'm going to
speak i'm going to say something that i
know is going to get you
because i'm going to win right when i
make a a fight with my wife and disagree
with my wife about a one and a loss i've
already lost
because we're on the same team and we're
fighting for the same thing we are we
are grinding out life together
and so when i cross that boundary and i
know i'm going to marry you with this
one
i've already lost because man yeah you
know what dr phillips does say
like do you want to be right or do you
want to be together
right am i am i fighting right now just
to be right
or am i trying to solve a problem
together so we can move on yeah
les pair talks about um one of the most
deadly
of forces in the marriage material that
he's done is contempt
the eye roll hmm that when someone's
gone
right it's the ultimate dismissal of
your personhood
right and that's that's the non-fair
thing
that's when you just you just said it
doesn't even matter what you think
because you don't matter
and think about that positionally right
that is me putting myself on a throne
saying i'm just brushing that off my
shoulder yeah right that's just dirty
away with you peasant that's right
that's right right
get that dirt off my shoulder yeah so i
i i've never done that
not me not in 38 years never